>> Tulsi: I'M SO HONORED TO BE
HERE FOR TUCKER AND TO
CONGRATULATE HIM ON THE GREAT
SUCCESS THAT HE'S SEEN OVER THE
YEARS AND TO SAY THANK YOU TO
ALL OF YOU WHO ARE CHOOSING TO
SPEND YOUR TIME HERE WITH US.
I'M SURE THAT TUCKER'S
SUPPORTERS AND DETRACTORS CANNOT
DENY THAT TUCKER IS CARRYING OUT
WHAT HE PROMISED TO DO.
>> WHAT IS THE SHOW GO TO BE
ABOUT?
YOU CAN JUDGE FOR YOURSELF.
PEOPLE IN POWER TEND TO LIE.
NOT BECAUSE THEY WANT TO BUT
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T HELP
THEMSELVES.
THAT'S HUMAN NATURE.
THE MORE POWER PEOPLE HAVE, THE
BIGGER THE TEMPTATION IS TO USE
IT.
THE PRESS IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
WATCH DOG.
IT WORKED FINE FOR A COUPLE
CENTURIES.
BUT THEN THEY DECIDED THEY HAD
MORE IN COMMON WITH CERTAIN
POLITICIANS.
>> THAT'S ABOUT IT FOR US
TONIGHT.
TUNE IN EACH NIGHT HERE